hey you know what is that what is good
Sims and Lefko and I I know that I'm the
third coolest person is right now that's
right you're damn right you're third I
know you're not first do some sense man
[ __ ] nice Cuba's here I don't even
know what to say I'm like I like that
inch I mean that's one of the best ones
I ever got you know yes he's dude he's
done too many things the man the metal
as you do much stuff you that's a good
thing I think it's great
we were I'm like actually like nervous
sitting here with you first well I'm
nervous in the fact of like I mean I
know he's a busy man he's got a million
things to do he's like who are these two
weird guys I'm sitting here talking to
and then we're making them listen to the
intro that's what we wanted to ask you
first this is a loyal listener to the
podcast who made that B it was pretty
good you think yes dope yeah it
definitely works for a radio bit right
sure right I know it's it's cool we got
a good little base I didn't realize you
have a Raiders anthem that you put out a
few years ago yeah yeah you know we put
out a you know a lot of writers good
because that's what we're hitting into
so you know you know they was they
needed one you know I was tired of
hearing the same old fans because of the
the automation pirate is greater yeah
that's that part is dope but you know I
was like yo didn't need any some more
flavor yeah I hope today you call
yourself the president of Raider Nation
I am just the president yes do you have
a VP I'm actually a dictator now I mean
they got a dictator running the football
team now he's my old my old head coach
too so that's what I'd like to start I
mean Johnny grew Dan back with the
Raiders yeah if you have any questions
about Gruden this guy will fill you in
but yeah tell me just your thoughts
about him Rena rejoining the franchise
and what it what
does to the fanbase I mean he's a great
football mind you know uh a tenure deal
is scary though right yes
they don't go cool in the first two
years you're like oh yeah right but hey
you know he's grateful well mine is it's
all about him connecting with this newer
generation and being able to get them to
play hard for him and so he that's his
job but he knows the exes the olds he
knows you know 3-step drop five steps
every step whatever 12 step being chased
so you know I think he's a great
football mind and let's see if he can
put it to work that was a really good PC
answer here's my question if a girl she
left to me
yes rated and was feuding without Davis
and then won a Super Bowl against my
team it would take me a little bit
longer I think when he gets announces
the new guy to be like I'm with you I'm
riding
was it immediate or was that weird cuz
of all the stuff that happened I mean
it's a little weird but if you look at
all the other coaches we've had you know
it's kind of like yeah please come back
and yes you know somebody get us to the
damn promised land
playoffs it was like a year year year
and you knew it wasn't the guy every
time and then Del Rio it felt like it
was gonna be you look like it was real
real was the guy you know I thought him
getting rid of musgrave was a crazy
crazy makes knows it don't make crazy
the beginning of the end right there
it was and I don't know why you know I
still love to know it can't be the fact
that he had a derrick are still dropping
back and throwing passes no but you're
only up by I think 11 in that game like
nine minutes eight minutes to go in the
game so it's not like you know sit on
the ball you had to steal play and
you're aggressive so I don't see why
yeah man well I know Groote ins
different when he was like calling out
Amari Cooper and I was like I didn't
know people talk to him ari Cooper I
thought we just let that quiet guy
staying alone well grew these amazing
he'll find the right way to blow Amari
Cooper and do
the right way to make them like building
back up and you're the man this is
awesome let's do this but yeah we got to
work on this - yeah he's not gonna give
him a free pass that's good yes I think
a mine needs work
yeah I think he needs is something
missing there that he needs to uh he's
so close together and and you know be
that guy we we know he could be every
week yes one of the best receivers in
football where where as the president of
the Raiders invader
sorry dictator your highness your your
highness your voice nice cute excellency
like what do you think what's the
Raiders fan base state of mind right now
I know of course we talked about Gruden
but of course the Vegas thing is the
elephant in the room and yeah it is
weird
I mean they're pissed where you at with
that I'm pissed too yeah I would be you
know because they didn't come to LA yeah
you know we're stuck with the Chargers
we got the charges and we got the
Clippers San Diego gotta stop using LA
as like a waste dump stop it you've been
using such a triple-a it seems like they
move up to LA and then they just leave
you know muddy up our waters you know
I'm saying so and the Lakers are either
comes the Raiders move to LA I mean
South Central right which I want to get
into all that too because of course you
know boys in the hood was like a staple
of my started hell with that [ __ ] but I
forgot where I was gonna go with that
where the hell I was gonna ask well
you're talking South Central you're
talking Hollow so wait what how did the
Raiders how did you become a fan of them
growing up in LA when the Rams were
there of course I mean I guess it was
was just the 70s Raiders got your
attention or was it when the Raiders
moved to LA in the 80s to where you
finally fully jumped on or when they got
my attention a little earlier you know I
was actually a big Pittsburgh Steelers
fan sure because
when I got into football they were
winning the championship so I was like
Cowboys and then Stiller's and then I
realized la we had a team the RAM so I
tried to get into them but it was a
situation where you know they weren't
good and they ended up moving to Anaheim
I playing in Anaheim which is Orange
County and so I was like yeah they left
us so I'm looking for a team and in the
Raiders they go to the Super Bowl and
beat the Eagles I know in 1980 I'm an
Eagles fan
yeah and I've always loved the Raiders
but my dad would always be like you
can't root for the Raiders because
they've ruined our dream in 80 that was
like yeah rain in the back of my mind
you know that team was supposed when
super ball always told me that the fact
they beat the Cowboys that was like
their Super Bowl because what the
Cowboys represented and then you guys
came out there I think the Eagles
partied a little bit but you guys that
was the first wild card team I believe
to win the Super Bowl
yeah so I ended up you know like getting
into them and then I started watching
them and liking them and they became my
favorite team and then my brother came
and told me what they like guess who's
moving their lake the Raiders I'm like
oh yeah Magic Johnson and now we're
gonna get the Raiders so that's how it
just kind of became a fan and you know
we're just you know they they the only
team to win a championship to win a
Super Bowl
for Los Angeles so you gotta love them
all right so how you gonna handle it
with a move to Vegas beyond the first
charter to Vegas you know you're not
like abandoning ship or anything like
that oh no cause you know I love Oakland
you know I think they played in a prison
though sucks like maximum security you
know I used to hate the locker room is
like the worst trust me so I understand
why they moving I don't understand why
they can't get a stadium built right
they're gonna tear that now
build some new right there so I don't
understand what's going on but I got to
fly anyway you know I mean it's like am
I gonna go an hour north right we'll go
our East what am I gonna do anyway I
gotta get on plane anyway it is Vegas so
I'm you know upset for the for the
Oakland fans but I'm happy for the Vegas
fans and and happy for me yeah late 80s
early 90s what you guys were doing it
changed everything
ladies early 90s phil simms was out
there ballin for the New York Giants
what did you think of Phil back then
real soon yeah we call big [ __ ] ya
know I thought he was a good solid
quarterback you know he to me reminds me
of what you you know if I opened the
dictionary to like quarterback yeah
right picture feels a pop-up but you
know I always thought he was a dog you
know I mean they dude who could win a
championship you know you got a salute I
got a guy who can deal with Bill
Parcells Huson and and and still not be
bitter you know I'm saying he's a dude
who's who's to me a guy that's that's
always carried yourself like a champion
and he should you know cuz he you know
he did great for the Giants thanks big
Phil's the man who seems kind of was
even not like how a quarterback more
than his you know this show man he's
cursing us out he's having a good time
and we're like man we want that fill all
the time all right this is our favorite
son that's why we have his picture up
yes secure the bag pay Odell his money
are you with us don't play make them pay
yeah especially in football how are ya
right especially in your deal with
athletes all the time you know that
these guys get screwed yeah they do you
know and especially football players you
know not having a guaranteed contract
you know and you could get injured so
you need to get paid yes you know as
much as you can fast you can as long as
you can yeah you could appreciate that
as a businessman - are you amazed
because we are amazed at times the
backlash like NFL players get about
money I mean nobody cares about Carmela
making twenty-eight million and they
want to make them the sixth man on the
bench in Oklahoma City yeah but here's
O'Dell ask him for 20 and like you said
it's football it's dangerous all that's
the most famous famous kind of sport
right now other than maybe Brady and
Rodgers yes and people are like oh [ __ ]
you know honor his contract I mean you
know whatever if you out play your
contract you know it's nothing wrong
with going in and yes it for more and he
deserves it I mean he's a good football
player I just realized you could be
really valuable if Odell said listen not
the best negotiator I'm a little too
nice ice can you walk into the room for
me and talk to Giants ownership what
would that be like I'll be the owner it
would be very simple very nice to meet
you mr. cube yeah kill on it
check this out we got the numbers mm-hmm
you know I'm saying we got the star
power you know the window is short for
four guys in football to really uh to
earn and make it and we got to do it or
he's not playing yeah that's really all
comes down to here is a period and just
walk out the room I like that yeah I
mean I think you know when you negotiate
and you gotta be willing to walk away
mmm before you even start right because
if not then you know you're just waiting
to be drug into a deal so you got to be
willing to walk away I actually love
that advice it is so hard you have big
three in your hat you have big three in
your wrist i you are big three yeah and
I guess my new name now I'm changing
from Ice Cube to be I can't imagine what
it's like running a league and the
amount of people that you deal with on a
daily basis but I will say that someone
passed us along you are you're gonna be
the first professional sports league to
legalize the use of CBD for pain
management yes we've been asking for
this the NFL for a very long time are
you drug testing in the big
good job I have a lot of PR stuff let
them do what they want to do but CBD it
just seems like every other sports
league should be doing this so props to
you man thanks man you know we
definitely pride ourselves and changing
the game you know we want to be
progressive yes for the right reasons
Yeah right not just change this to
change but when we see something that
needs to be better or needs to be done
better let's let's do it we you know we
have a league we can do that without
making our game you know foreign or look
you know like it it doesn't make sense
so you know this to me is is the future
yeah you know so why be late on the
future when you could be early and so we
wanted to be first to the party because
we know this is the future and
eventually all leagues will allow I have
to we do left Gopi are right now last
names left Co when I give advice to
people can I give you two big three
ideas the ideas hell yeah all right
we're going in a week - yes one thing I
saw from week one it was everywhere mmm
Kenyon Martin's mom okay you got a fight
between the players one embrace that
love that it's perfect
what if first idea you line the front
row you sell four tickets but you put
everyone's mom because no one gets
angrier than moms right I'm a fan one of
my favorite things was watching
Iverson's mom during the games II put
the moms out there Len come out there
grab an ear punch somebody who knows I'm
not gonna do second idea you know how
everyone there's like it's a big three
you put a fourth seat on each bench
mm-hm and it's for a random fan it's for
a famous person whoever they want to
pick but the other team gets to pick
who's on their bench so if you wouldn't
put someone annoying like a Kevin Hart
Gilbert Godfrey or just to break up
their imagine in the finals if the
Warriors set one of those Tristan
Thompson girls to sit on the Cavs ball
wow that's great and it's like a
distraction option for the other team
well that could get a little personal
that far listen man who are they gonna
pick that night - in the big three great
TV let's do it what do you like it
I like that too they you know moms
trash-talk into a little league game
parents are the worst I can't get over
it I like it she hears me you talk about
it all the time cuz I'm like the kids
eight he's not going to the pros yet
relax dad it's not that quickly
Hanley crisis funny to hear like Kenyon
mother's saying what did you forget that
coach no because that's not a parent's
be coach I've learned that through a
number of players all right I wanna have
just like some fun questions I mean of
course your movie Straight Outta Compton
that came out I mean I know it wasn't
your movie but it was about you guys and
NWA and everything about it tomorrow
yeah it's yours right it is yours it you
actually met he did make it yes that's
actually fascinated of course by
everything I mean there's so many things
I want to go here and want to tie it
into today and all the the police
brutality and the issues were having in
the NFL but first I just want to ask you
fun questions about it just back in the
day how you know the movie the parties
everything alike as crazy as it seemed
in the movie and everything or crazier
and yes time growing up this was like
another world this is to me I'm not no
joke Dubai I was so excited to see you
today was not only is NWA my first like
chased into gangster rap as the white
kid from northern New Jersey but then
boys in the hood was like my first like
man that's [ __ ] up how they treat
black people in the hood yeah and then
of course just tying it all together
with your movie which was a great movie
I'm just I'm tempted I just wanna hear
that some of the stories all and just
how amazing it was it was pretty well
you know it got pretty well but we had
fun through the whole thing you know
that's was like I guess what people trip
off from that we was in this whirlwind
of controversy but we were we were
having the time of our lives as it was
better than what we was doing so
in the hood you know hanging out you
know saying so and you were the ones
making waves yeah so it was great and
and it's a trip because we never thought
this music would see the light of day
like we made it just because we knew it
would make us famous in our neighborhood
right right all the homies is not loaded
right just record and and so so
surprisingly like you know great it's
like the gift that keeps on giving you
know it's like Publishers Clearing House
or something you know it's like they
come you got a check oh man and you get
this every week it's like damn this is
great and then the controversy come and
you have to grow up real fast yeah you
have to you have to understand yourself
on this political stage and where you
fit in and and what are all the politics
that's that's going on in place so you
you end up growing up real quick and
getting a real you know is that gonna
make things tough on you guys like you
know what I mean just as you guys
personally when did it get tough to
where like you know you new realize
people are unhappy with the business
dealings or they wanted their size you
know what it's like when the money come
in that's it and then when you come in
you know it's like wait a minute what
did you get what did you get uh-huh well
I don't well I'm only getting this so
now you're trying to catch up with your
understanding of the business yes some
guys telling you about points and
publishing and royalties and you know
you like my money I just I know I did as
much as this dude yeah I need as much as
he got and it just don't work like that
so that's when a lot of confusion comes
in it's when it's when the business
really like when the money come in
everybody starts to cut it up and people
realize what they're really old and then
that's when they like huh yeah so I
really think Ice Cube just told the
Julio Jones story like the money came in
one hundred million dollars he goes why
am I getting half a Matt Ryan yes yeah I
mean like that like as a human you go do
you value me as much as him no then we
got a problem we got a problem we got a
problem so that's really how it usually
breaks down
you know it's usually when that money
come in before the money everything is
called everything's amazing because
you're like we're gonna make all this
stuff yeah all right I have some fan
questions on Twitter
greasemonkey X how many championships
will it take for Gruden's tenure tenure
to be considered successful I'll take
one yeah I'll do it yeah I like that
so Strauss key hey Ice Cube take it easy
on these guys I've listened since the
beginning and they are right thank you a
question what game are you most excited
for this season let me bring up the
schedule Rams at Broncos at dolphins
Browns at chargers Seahawks although I'm
gonna bind my boy is the head coach of
the 49ers ice just so you know it's not
interested in none of those guys those
the first games of the year
this is the whole schedule and who the
Raiders is a plan yes it's always cool
to whoop up on the Broncos mmm you know
them Seahawks is gonna be tough I hate
to chiefs do you have extra hate for the
49ers because they're in the Bay Area or
anything no no I love a 49 yeah I have
no hate for the 49ers but I'm circling
sheesh
chief goes week 14 Steelers oh yeah yeah
thing right there you know it's like you
know that's that's that goes way back
like did you guys smoke a lot of weed on
Friday when you were like actually fell
on the show yeah on the set like did you
actually like would you ever do seems
high I like do that way I've done since
high in a movie where I'm supposed to be
high yeah right you know the trans be me
yeah blend the trailer don't do it but
but uh you know it was we smoked you
know not on set yes you know saying cuz
this was our first movie and we just we
were shooting it in the hood for 20 days
two million dollar budget so we didn't
know if like the LAPD was gonna pull up
on us at any time and be like what what
the hell's goin on y'all shut down yeah
what do I smell here
we was being cool on that movie and we
want to get it right but you guys nailed
it
next Friday Friday out the next you know
Oh classics man he actually went and I
fell in love with next Friday because it
was just so ridiculous yes and then I
went back and watched Friday so many
more times but next Friday it was my jam
this one's Liam batchly to this point
with how many Raiders players have you
smoked weed already also none none any
famous Raiders players in history no I'm
not gonna you know yes that's called
rice knits well just let you know I'm
willing to smoke weed with you any time
okay man which guy awesome I got
something here this I knew I got it yeah
yeah I got a story so Jerry Rice is 55
years old okay and he said I still feel
like today if I wanted to come back to
football and play football I could do it
I think I'm still explosive and I think
I can still beat up on some defense man
do you think he can no I don't think so
hell's Jerry's mind is correct why he's
Jerry that's what you want though yeah
you kind of want like you want those
guys who you know you won't Bill Russell
saying like yeah I could still post it's
like nah man cuz you still got that fire
in your belly yeah you know since you
like Jerry Rice the Raider I did yeah I
think they use them enough in the
Superbowl yeah they didn't we lost that
Super Bowl because of Bill Callahan
exactly come down how do you not change
the Damn signals and the audibles and
all the things that they were taught to
the offense by the old coach you're
playing in the Super Bowl is still
amazing that is mind-boggling
it's my bomb when he said we're not
doing anything different yeah I almost
fell out my chair man that Prescott once
I learned the often I can't I got
drafted by the Bucs
a few months after that yes I came right
after the Super Bowl and once I learned
the story and all that and just the talk
around the locker room about the game I
was
from that moment on I've always been
like what the hell would the Raiders
doing did they really think Jon Gruden
wasn't gonna teach Warren Sapp and
Simeon rice and Ronde Barber the checks
and John Lynch like what what yeah what
are you thinking what were you thinking
and then just Barret Robbins crap and
that was that was a high scream oh yeah
all right Raider homie you have the best
diss track of all time
no Vaseline what did you think of Pusha
T and Drake I was good you know it's up
there I think you know sometimes dudes
go too far and put your team on too far
am i yeah you go too far when you start
talking about like Keith and your parent
mothers yes I gripes you going too far I
agree straighter then you know it's like
you know you play football and there's
no like somebody going in the stands
after your mom's song it's like what I'm
gonna feel man suit up and hit me that's
right and so it's it went too far and
but you know dissin is good for hip-hop
it's good for the culture it is so good
long as it doesn't like turning a true
real violence right school I think what
was was so wild I heard this no Vaseline
you released it like six or seven months
after they called you out right I don't
know exact time but I know that I end up
putting it on my next or next record a
new album blew up and then you were solo
but the reason it's so funny to me is
now six seven months if guys don't
respond in like six seven days yes it's
too long yeah it's too long it's too
long imagine that back then like it's I
could you know I could see it but it's a
whole new day with this social media you
know if I if I told you back then that
you know 1988 came and said you know
what in the future mmm you would have to
pay for water and music would be free
you look at me you're right it's a whole
new world right now that is that's a
great way to put it all right yeah I'm
gonna try and do a social thing here
okay if you are mr. big three if you had
to pick big three from the raid
roster right now who would you pick who
is your big three on the current Raiders
roster I mean this Derek Carr yeah Mauri
right and Khalil yeah
Khalil man yeah that's the big three so
on the big three Mount Rushmore the
Raiders those are the three on the team
that's a big time 2018 right yes yeah
what about all-time all-time oh my god
you gotta go I mean I love there's so
many damn players you want to go Lester
the molester I mean Lester Hayes is one
of my favorite writers I got Jack Tatum
okay you know yeah that's worth a up
there right got Kenny Stabler yeah and I
think yeah and uh give me like John
Madden the white shirt ah give me you
know he was our speedster right so
Biletnikoff was like Johnny white guy
receiver on the other side and branch
was the guy that everybody I swear push
the dog they were like oh [ __ ] he's the
one that the Raiders go deep in out
Davis likes to go deep it was it was
branch that was the one that was doing
yes yeah he was the man you know Jim
Plunkett what Marcus Allen what yeah man
man you putting that thing come back to
Marcus Allen right what was that about
was all about him getting back in the
fold you know back in the Raider phone
man yeah he needs to know you know the
issue with him and now I think how
that's when he lost Los Angeles is when
he you know we didn't play I want to see
what does it make you feel like it gives
me goose play tells me to I'm John I'm
like ready to go let's go play guys yeah
it makes you ready for football man
it is amazed at hor it's a powerful song
that it really is so you have such a
southern cow that must have been tough
for you to deal with that big are you a
USC fan like do you root for them I'm
not big on colleges you know I'm in and
out when it comes to college right you
know
I'm the same manner go watch the college
games right I agree with you all right
last one and then I want you to do some
more big three before we get out of here
evil jester o1 hashtag softball for kube
why are the Raiders the greatest team in
NFL history ah because of the image it's
the image of football it's it's that
rough and tough image that you know
they're trying to clean out of the game
yeah
renegade yeah that we love so much that
goes back as far as rugby you know or
when they played you know with the skull
I'm sorry so when people died on the
football field it goes back to those
days so the Raiders remind me of the
essence of why we like football and
they're the perfect team name perfect
team colors perfect logo for you know a
football team yeah I love it I think
that's guilty because you are ice cube
and you have way bigger things to do
other than talk to us but I mean like we
talked about a little earlier just the
state of our country right now and the
way it's playing out in football with
the social injustice and the kneeling
anthem thing and Malcolm Jenkins Jenkins
right and there's you know the players
where do you where do you think this
should go like I am one I am all for the
cost don't get me wrong and I am NOT the
biggest fan of our president okay but
the other thing I would say is I do look
at it and going the kneeling for the
national anthem I don't think we can win
that fight right no so we're we have to
find another way I just would like to
hear your two cents on the whole
situation well you know I think you know
kneeling and that whole thing I knew
that he was gonna get mixed I was gonna
get hijacked right you know once Colin
Kapernick connected police brutality
with making a protest with the flag I
knew that you know the the you know kind
of American you know that kind of yeah
American pride right that bravado would
false paper traitors would override
a lot of some people is not false you
know some people really into it but you
got to understand the essence of freedom
yeah and the essence is you could do
what you want to do in that anthem is
plan and that's what that's the great
thing about this country you don't have
to stand you can lay down if you want to
you can go get you a beer right you can
you can go to the bathroom you can sit
down you can kneel you know I'm saying
and that to me is really what it's all
about it's not all about making
everybody stand up and making everybody
do something that they necessarily don't
want to do because that's not freedom to
me so I believe NFL got it wrong you
know and you know it's getting to the
point where do we need the national
anthem at a sporting event
we can't just play no it's why you know
is you know you come so divisive and and
you know so it's the big three is all
about basketball yeah we all about
basketball you come you're gonna see
basketball there's gonna be no
controversy yeah over the flag trust me
okay this I appreciate you sharing that
seriously you're amazing
this Friday week twos could be the
United Center in Chicago and then week
three is going to be in Oakland
California Oracle so I'm sure you're
excited about that one do you have some
rate in Mason up yeah we're gonna get
some moms on the sidelines we're gonna
get some fancy people on the bench yeah
what can we look forward to moving
forward in the big three season
congratulations on year two by the way
thank you I think the guys are in better
shape they know what to expect now so
we're seeing the strategies come into
play
you know we're seeing guys really really
understanding that this is pro
basketball and and you have to get
yourself ready to play and so we got
some new additions to the league like
Metta World Peace yeah and Baron Davis
and they Robinson Amar'e Stoudemire
perfect hollows are perfect yeah in a
Christmas Bert Bertman is Anson so you
know they're new to the league so they
found out game one that oh yeah right
Nate Robinson's perfect because they'll
fight anybody he's I feel like that guy
has had to prove himself his entire life
and people are still messily yeah
without a doubt and you know when he saw
a Rashad McCants coming to the arena
with that massacre mass Nate lost it
he's like what just dude really
disrespecting the game yeah and he just
like he just took it upon itself to
teach Rashad or less man I hope that
everything goes great with the big three
this season and I got that Amari Cooper
becomes the Joker yeah I hope that he
comes out this year and we don't even
recognize him yeah as a Raiders fan I
think it's the best gift I can give you
is that way Thank You Man yeah we need
some trash talking from you hell yeah in
the AC we need you to get busy and back
on the big three before I go just check
us out on Facebook our first game is on
Facebook line oh nice and in games two
through four are on big Fox so big [ __ ]
big Fox you you see it's on what's this
Brian okay so check us out 8 o'clock
Eastern for big Fox 7 o'clock Eastern on
Facebook you made basic cable with with
big 3 that's an accomplishment I mean
you know we took it from you know some
fs1 most yes nice but we got almost half
our nights on big Fox basic cable big
Fox I don't know what is that that's
like bit bets above basic cable I think
that's amazing and if you ever need like
guest commentary say what's up to you
pie well he's coming on next yeah you
know him he's the second best guy we had
on here today though no problem good
luck dude thanks be good so ice cube
just left and I forgot I had this
picture of ice cube that definitely goes
in the room that's amazing and
was like oh let me sign that I was like
I didn't think about that so he wrote
stay up IceCube yeah we're decorating
the walls and this undressing going up
sorry for stealing sorry yeah I'm gonna
put in front of Odell you were nervous I
was nervous I I mean when you send me
the text that he was coming in yesterday
I was like genuinely excited because can
I ask you about the that's my problem
I can't even get my answers my questions
out what's things like stuttering all of
it was I want to ask I want to be like I
want to ask so many things behind the
scenes and just like what's he like
what's that guy like what was this like
that's what I really wanted to do yeah
and I know that I can't bother him with
all that why he's got limited time but
man was great he was a truly I hope I
like said that the right way he was a
big part of my childhood yeah he really
was because because of NWA and like I
said boys in the hood that was that's
like an Alzheimer for me because of what
it stood for and some of the messages
that put out there right I don't think
you're wrong yeah I really think that
that's what they always say about NWA is
that it people didn't realize that
America was actually gonna listen to
that type of messaging and music and it
really took hold in white neighborhoods
just really crazy
have we ever tell influential they were
have we ever had a greater transition in
cool factor to go from this chair to
have Ice Cube down to me
I feel biggest transition in the history
of entertainment right back stock market
2008 I apologize to everyone out there
do you want to draw up a freestyle real
quick no absolutely not
did you know it's like yes he's like no
I get paid for I mean I'm not to smoke
with them both other than that bonding
I'm sure it did I asked you afterwards I
was like what is it like when you've
done stuff for like 30 years and people
ask you about old stuff I go it is it
annoying because I don't know
yeah and he was like no it's actually
cool because like all these memories pop
up and I feel like I'm back in that time
yeah just time itself is crazy but he's
he's done something in almost every
decade yeah and now I
sincerely mean this being a commissioner
of a sports league what yeah the amount
of time and entered and that's nuts no
you have to be sitting back collecting
she's driven human being yes alright so
you want to call your dad yep he says to
call the house guys better to call the
house that's another one yes so he
actually he said give a shout out to big
Phil I know well they know each other no
not at all but he said that when you
look up quarterback in the dictionary
Phil Simms is there wasn't a big fan of
his announcing did you offer his opinion
what do you say is like he's a very but
proper or square in the words of Sims
real real Joe company man who Joey
company man you know those CBS Blazers
by the way that no Vaseline question I
made hello man yes that's right we are
men we are men that just interviewed Ice
Cube I would love to heard that man or I
will listen to it what do you what do
you know about Ice Cube I don't know
much but I know he probably thinks you
two or two whites where it did I think
that's I asked him I said I said look I
said back then NWA late 80s early 90s
you guys were everywhere late 80s early
90s
big phil simms was everywhere and he
said that i said what do you think about
phil simms did when you look up big Phil
in the dictionary or at quarterback in
the dictionary there's big phil dealing
with Bill Parcells and winning Super
Bowls so he was very complimentary oh
that's nice thank you
good well he's he's cool too he's done
it all and he can say whatever he wants
cuz he's made a lot of money so if you
don't like what he says he can just tell
you where to go big Phil what do you
remember from nwa back when you're
playing you know asking me about i can't
even come up with a good analogy I was
gonna say something I got in trouble for
there but let's put it that way yeah do
you remember how crazy it was back then
though I remember
like the president was talking about
them and all that stuff you know Adam my
I got so many things in my head I can't
really remember all of them but if you
want to refresh me with some of it I
maybe I could remember yeah he's
referring to cuz like NWA
you know they were there were some
controversial songs there late 80s Early
90s against the police like so Adams I
guess wondering if he thought like do
you remember players playing in a locker
room anything like that
although I'm sure they did and I
probably didn't realize it wasn't
listening to the words right and no I
don't remember you know being offended
by it I really can't remember that time
when that was going on so that was the
late 80s yeah that was a lady you know I
didn't think about anything but just
what was happening with our football
team yeah that's damn right you didn't
who controlled the locker who controlled
the locker room music actually in the
old days
you know a good question I know I wasn't
in control of it was dude the d-line did
they usually have control of it her well
you don't listen
it was probably no wouldn't been it
could have been a receiver that was you
know in the weight room defensive
linemen in certain groups you know they
were a groups that were gonna stay in
the weight room a long time right so the
offensive line surely wasn't in control
of the music yeah because all I wanted
to hear what they wanted yes I would say
probably our wide receivers because you
know they were ones I played with most
of them were great workers on the field
and the weight room and all that they
played the music and you know I've told
you this many times I think they thought
you know by the time I was in my 30s
oh what's this song tell us the same but
this one yeah okay yeah right I wasn't
I've listed some music every once a
while on the way down the to the stadium
and back and forth because you know
mostly in my career
talk radio isn't what it is now
so in fact until I think what the mid
80s there was old sports talk radio
right I think WFA in here in New York
came about when 80 yes happen 87
so I think so yes you listen sports
radio with Walker used to listen to Mike
in the mad dog I remember on the way
home because it was such a big thing and
I was like man my dad's listening to
this they're talking crap about him on
the Giants right there are people
talking crap about you on the radio it
was like the only thing in town you
talking to me yeah I'm talking to you
later yeah now what's that oh my gosh
you don't know hell you both were
talking you know such a quarterback I
was saying you would drive home or be in
a car and listening to Mike and the mad
dog talking [ __ ] about you like after a
game well of course not I'm not gonna
listen to anybody tell me what's good
and bad and whatever I didn't read it
and I didn't listen to it you didn't I
don't believe I listened to this works
talk radio as soon as they bring up the
Giants I'd turn it over
Yeah right okay no there's many times ya
wouldn't even look at the newspapers I
might walk by and look out a corner of
mine go oh I didn't see much I'm gonna
keep on walking yeah you know just you
know and I was pretty good at it and I
could always tell who wrote a bad
article about me after a game whatever I
did my interviews they would always kind
of stand in the back of the pack and
hoping I would look at them or call them
out or something and say you got a
question and you know everyone so I'd
have fun ago hey it's okay you don't the
hide back there my man you know what you
wrote so don't worry about it it's okay
you know and they'd laugh Oh Phil you
know okay you know that I don't know
never I've never asked you this and I
know I've had to tell stories like this
recently so that's why I want to bring
it up as we were in the the music
conversation there who was the the
baddest [ __ ] in your locker room
who didn't nobody want to mess with it
was the ultimate like I know my guess
well I know I know I don't think we're
good
yes SLT okay I think it's gonna be Jim
Burt oh you'd be right Jim Burt was the
nose tackle for the Giants and I like a
dumptruck yep and then he he went on to
play for the 49ers in 89 and 90 and he
won Super Bowls out there he's the one
that instigated the fight between my dad
and Ronnie Lott after the Monday night
game because he went up there and talked
crap about dad and said dad said all
these things about their defense to kind
of get them motivated
and then dad and Ronny had it out after
the game yeah yeah but so he doesn't
write a buck up my chin strap and said
help somebody's gonna swing I'm ready
what so but he was the guy that nobody
messed with in a lot you know Jim was
very flexible he was I don't know if he
was in karate or all that stuff growing
up judo I mean he had hands that were
thicker then you know put three hands on
top of each other that was his right and
if he grabs your any part of your body
you were dead right and he was he was
one of the best two gapper Technique
guys in the NFL and I would think it
always said he would be the one of the
best if not the best d-line coach and
the National Football League if that's
what he decided to do you know he's a
business man when did other things but
he was limber those big hands of stones
and he wasn't afraid of anybody
and it was notorious I'm not gonna
spreading rumors but I think he got in a
few fights over the years as he was a
player yes yeah yeah it was a good time
to do it because nobody would report it
there were no cameras and all that kind
of stuff but you know Jim to this day I
saw him um Monday night at the all-star
game in New Jersey high school all-star
game and he still got those hands he is
an unbelievable shape and I don't think
it would take much to this day to get
him riled up and going so anybody out
there that doesn't know Jim birdie was
64 on the 86 Giants he's the guy that
kills Joe Montana
you've seen the highlight shows it and
gets it killed and then LT picks it off
and runs it first pick six but it's a
famous highlight you'd see it was a
divisional playoff game and he knocks
Mountain at Montana
out of the game Joe about it it was
really the ones every brought up
yeah you said that's the hardest hit
that no and he was like no actually the
other Giants it was the harder one he's
like Leonard Marshall was worse and I
was like oh damn you're right I forgot
about that
I couldn't see the one with Jim Burke
coming on when it did all our members a
gym hitting Joe
literally flew in the air yes because he
was coming off a back surgery that
season he meant
the season and he was extremely thin and
you know so man playing on their turf
cold weather against our defense I mean
oh my gosh it was a recipe for disaster
and it happened and but the hit you're
talking about is in the 1990 season
championship game in San Francisco and
Leonard Marshall was at midfield Joe
Montana ran out of pocket was outside
the numbers looking down the field and I
swear I was almost gonna yell Joe look
out because you're hurt on the sidelines
and yeah I mean I could see it coming
ago Oh Mike oh my gosh and Leonard if he
don't put his helmet until him who knows
what could have happened but general
course did not come back in the game and
it's true story I didn't ever listen but
they told me Pat Summerall the great
voice yes well we just got a report from
the 49ers [ __ ] Joe Montana will not
return he has overall body yeah
everything the report on Montana is
everything hurts but yeah so those those
are big hits and then you're but going
back to the original story yes Jim Burt
that yeah
okay so this week apparently is rookies
buy things for their parents week I
guess the paychecks first cleared DJ
more got his mom Mercedes say Quan got
his mom a house I'm seeing other houses
Phil did you buy anything with your
first paycheck for uh for mom dad you
know come up with anything oh man you
know I'm embarrassed to tell you what I
got you know I see my first year I made
sixty thousand and I made seventy
thousand I made eighty thousand I made
ninety thousand so let's take some taxes
out of that spend a little money when I
what's left at him and my son
Christopher yes okay but I bought him
what I guess my first biggest thing I
did I did have a car when I came to New
Jersey my dad let me the money to buy a
car so when I came up here he asked
could I send the car back to give it to
my younger brother who was coming back
from college
was whatever I said okay so then I had
to go look for a car so that was like
the first thing I did but over the years
would you buy what did I buy at us at
the car back yeah I actually got a deal
with a cadillac dealer philadelphia
they kind of like never gave me one back
or whatever I was like you jerks I like
to say their name but they're out of
business you know few tickets and phil
simms top ten draft pick $60,000 as a
rookie yeah I mean these guys probably
making I don't know what the lowest was
at the time but you know evers guys
making twenty I think twenty five and
thirty thousand so you know every five
thousand was a big deal back then it
really was Jalen Ramsay said something
about our boy Jimmy Garoppolo aka Joe
Montana in bed aka Jimmy G Q Ramsey
saying that Jimmy G should not have been
on the top 100 list saying not yet
what is he played five games he has good
potential I think he's a good player
but in my experience playing him this is
a little compliment - Kyle Shanahan yeah
it was a lot of scheme stuff it wasn't
like he was dicing it up it was a lot of
scheme one Phil do you agree with Ramsey
or do you think that Garoppolo is a top
100 already well first off we make too
much of this top 100 list
oh it's crap players yeah no I know we
be proud crapped all over I don't know
let's sort of mean I can't even think of
a hundred guys in the league right and a
half of them don't watch the other half
during the year what do you think about
his take though that Garoppolo is mainly
Shanahan scheme at this well look when
they played the Jacksonville Jaguars
that seemed
yeah we know me and dad knew this is
going to happen it was great I mean they
had all the plays to beat to beat that
defense cows a man knows it very well
had had great success
with the Atlanta Falcons yeah he's
practicing against in Atlanta he's
probably not against these 49ers yeah
all the beaters in there and they all
worked and Jalen Ramsey is right and you
know he's right to the Jimmy Garoppolo
should not have been in one of the top
100 players in the league I mean agreed
five games I mean so old I shows you
something I love this and we make such a
big deal if it's on TV you don't know we
need something to talk about but talk
about something a little better than oh
who's the top 100 players
I mean Christopher Adam you should see
Pro Bowl voting how that works yeah I
know okay I know what do you mean
well the pliers the pliers even when
they do that they're kind of coulis
maybe that's I think that's what you're
referring to right sure I just write
rate Louis he retired oh he doesn't play
anymore
exactly you're right where they asked
but you're right I mean I can remember
filling out Pro Bowl ballots and
defensive guys going like you know I
haven't seen him who would you vote for
Chris who you know so that's how it goes
down so you tell me the Bucks were very
accurate that year in Pro Bowl well no
no you know my thought about what Derek
did my Derrick Brooks would fall into
the Ray Lewis thing right where he would
get voted even when he was Brooks and
Derrick Brooks Hall of Famer we know
that this lame-ass but he was literally
the worst player in our defense one year
like the worst and I'm not trying to be
a jerk like he was the worst player in
the defense and everybody on the team
knew it and he went to the Pro Bowl and
then ended up getting 2 tip passes that
he caught four interceptions it became
the MVP of the Pro Bowl you know we've
had this discussion I had it on a radio
station about the Hall of Fame I want to
want to get into it and all that and I
think we probably did it already and who
votes but I want to be a voter for the
Pro Football Writers Hall of Fame I
wanted a I've been saying that Dad
that's how I could know yeah with some
other interviews I just still talk just
strictly to you guys
sick and tired of going phil simms says
to local New Yorker pay obj O'Dell it's
literally all we talk about here that
man his money yeah you're stealing it
you're amusing rounders quotes I don't
like it Phil
day that money that paid up man his
money he beat me fair and square
hey dad do you know what one thing I'm
gonna have them both you to hear this
when he talked about the Joe Montana he
was in the yell watch out yeah I did
that once in a game to the other team's
quarterback oh wow
Jake Dell home Carolina Panthers big
third down were winning in Carolina
I had a great robbery thought I'd always
thought what happened if I yelled watch
out and the other quarterback could hear
me in a little dead spot right I don't
know this of course I have no
confirmation but I promise you he's a
big third down and I reeled watch out
Jake and I'm telling you the mother ever
flinched and looked around and ended up
doing incompletion and I never told
anybody that first time I ever told
about was he in trouble or did you just
yell I just yelled and nobody around him
but he he buckled for a second and
looked behind him and then threw an
incompletion and I just I never have
told anybody that story but I always
thought that's what the opposing team
should do every now and then yelled at
his quarterbacks can hear that crap
it's muttered are you sensitive yeah
you've got the right angle all that oh
man I used to do all that stuff run to
the line of scrimmage real quick and
know it's what act like he goes what's
the damn count I said it's for sound you
know you gone you know everybody here
may go yeah I'd yell row they tell balls
and Barton look bardos and I look at
these oh just our lap and it works every
time it was yeah and like couples little
live scrimmage like we get to run the
ball but running out of time and you
know we're never gonna run a play and
they all give the hard count and and
then we did the old have the guard
whip-snap count well it's Tuesday
Tuesday you know course everybody knows
that's too right so you know we tried
all that stuff I would up in practice
one day and did not get under the sitter
you know I was looking around
I have my hands on my knee looking
around I said Green 88 green he says
pain and made a real loud snap count I
took off you know to the right side like
I was going in motion and of course the
defense jumped offsides and Parcells
just starts screaming that message bill
I just want to do it this is legal we
need I can use this in the game oh you
and all your tricks just try to do
something right once you know we don't
need no tricks in it I thought it was a
you know it was awesome right
quarterback going in motion kind of
looking around all this I just take off
and you know course the other side's
gonna jump Yeah right and he wouldn't
let me do it yeah yeah that's a shocker
I stole the paid man he's not the
greatest one of all time with us when he
it was the end of the half and he looked
over to the sideline like I can't hear
what you're doing and then everybody
thought like oh the place stopping and
they snapped in the ball and he got up
and acted like wait what's going on and
he ran started running towards the end
zone like man we messed it up and he was
making all these and he was trying to
run for a touchdown the clock was
running and somebody tackled him and
realized it do you remember this at all
Marino fakes spike Jonas and the Ben
Roethlisberger fakes spike against the
Cowboys in the regular season were both
great yes but you're telling me Peyton
sold it Hayden sold it like he got
snapped the ball and he wasn't supposed
to get the snap the ball everybody
started to and he looked at the
sidelines with his hands up and he you
know giving his old like you know how
Payton does his all shucks jolly guy
George oh gosh and he started doing that
but he was running towards the locker
room like the half was over but the snap
was going he was running and finally
somebody tackled him just before he got
there you know one thing about the fake
Dan Marino spike yeah I don't know who
Mark Ingram caught the touchdown but the
coroner was not fooled
it was Erin Glen and he was not fooled
at all you know he didn't hit fold it
was just a little back shoulder throw
that Erin Glenn couldn't get to but he
did not fall asleep he was ready and he
just couldn't make the play but let's
don't let that get in the way of it he
fooled the defense yeah why does the
first time I guess anybody ever really
did it that way right
that's true too yeah all right so Phil
gambling is legal and we have if you
know you know 2018 regular-season MVP
odds are in I have the list in front of
me the first 17 guys that are predicted
to possibly win MVP are all quarterbacks
really stupid the first 17 from Rodgers
at 13 to 2 all the way to Stafford at 30
to 1 which let me be honest great oz for
Matt Stafford I'm gonna read out some
names and you tell me
who should be at the top Phil who are
your top three guys for MVP for next
season oh my gosh this is such a let me
say this some defensive player would
have to set the sack record and score 14
touchdowns before they'll give it to a
defensive player that's their defensive
guy that I see here is JJ Watt and he's
at a hundred to one she hasn't played in
two years but okay yeah well Donald is
right like goes the camp and gets a
contract man I'd have his butt up there
high because boy Wade Phillips he's
probably on vacation sitting somewhere
right now I don't know if he drinks or
not he goes honey let's go out dance
tonight because I'm a hell of a year
like a great dancer too so you know it's
got that but now there was a question it
was who should be at the top of the MVP
oh my god Russell Wilson okay Oh team
cannot be how can Seattle be a 12 win
team Aaron Rodgers is at 13 to to
Brady's at 7 to 1 whence is it 19 to 2
then it goes breeze at 11 is Jared Goff
at 22 to 1 that's insane and we have a
tie at 66 to 1 right this is much
further down the list the two guys at 66
to 1
Phil are you ready Gus are you ready
ready alvin kamara
at 66 2 1 ok
no Choa no chance okay Blake bortles
note 66 2 1 now those are the two alvin
kamara and blake bortles have an equal
chance of winning MVP no way there's no
way I'll tell you I like a bet list okay
and I'll tell you the rods okay you'll
tell me I'm wrong
no no I'm excited oh I say Drew Brees
Drew Brees coming in at number four yeah
15 to 1 yeah I think they're gonna be
good right and team I mean it's boy just
think now you know they were out of
nowhere last year I picked them as my
Dark Horse to go to the Super Bowl and I
did it on Showtime the opening show and
everybody thought I was an idiot you
know that you stole that from Chris from
Christopher we might have talked about
it but I do the Saints not steal them
for me he did not these are things that
dad and I dad watch this film like me I
mean we're the preseason games I go
alright god they're one thing they're
gonna be they might not be any good but
Sean Payton is making them I mean he
wants their preseason game a Monsieur
Garron killing people they were they
were like you couldn't even watch them
he just lined up and let's all get
inside the hashes and I'm just gonna run
it up the middle every play all right
send a message to make everybody tops
get a there Colts are going and it
finally carried over for him in the
season Phil who else for MVP anyone else
other than jus Brees know who comes in
my mind after that you know of course
Tom Brady I'm gonna say Tom bringing the
usuals
you know Mike Patton being the defensive
coordinator in Green Bay
man listen he is a no-nonsense get in
your face and he is almost like a coach
he no I don't know like if you talk back
to him he might fight you Yeah right and
I'll tell you what I wouldn't want to
fight him no that's just he is
well I say he's big-boned is the kind of
more the way to say it yes everything
but you know Green Bay you know a little
better maybe I'm deep in some young guys
but he's creative he's think teaches
them to be really tough and maybe that
could give that Green Bay offense a
better chance and then you know Aaron
Rodgers could have a much greater chance
of what in the MVP right so that would
be boy I don't know if it's a dark horse
but I think Aaron Rodgers chances of
being the MVP this year I know everybody
everybody thinks he should be the guy
every year because they don't it's you
know they just see Aaron Rodgers and
they think oh okay he should be in the
MVP they don't realize he has no help
any names stick up to you Chris well I
mean I'm just amazed I am amazed I mean
it's just we've put the quarterback on
such a pedestal it's absolutely
disgusting I just don't even know what
to mean the top 17 guys levy on Belvin
Todd Gurley or 1890 David Johnny on bail
is 40 to 1 and says at the 18th most
like how can Todd Gurley not be I mean
Tiger Lee is the best player on the Rams
last year when it came down to the
finalists for the MVP yes it was Tom
Brady Carson Wentz Le'Veon Bell Antonio
Brown tog early not even levy on bail
Antonio Brown Todd Gurley yeah two of
the four were non quarterback hey you
don't listen Christopher you said no way
let me tell you another year
Jared golf with that offense and
everything that's going on excuse me one
second yeah pick it up
yeah no I'm not gonna pick it up it's no
I know yes Jim doctor hell I don't want
to talk to them I know what you're gonna
say yeah I mean you're saying yeah
there's a chance he could win it I know
but I absolutely yeah I will be public
enemy number one on that one I can
promise you that well I got you yeah
yeah I know you're right you know people
say to me all the time the contracts and
I said you know the contracts are
actually getting they're getting so big
now I'm getting a little jealous right
but they always ask me all those things
I said you know I'm jealous of the fact
that what we know now how to take care
of our bodies and all that but I said
really what makes me more jealous than
anything is the control
that quarterbacks have with their
offenses now and all the quarterback are
the coordinators that you can be
mediocre and you're gonna do it you're
gonna end up looking like a star because
they're so good so creative then they
just keep giving you stuff we're all
right throw this one left handed if you
want it won't matter he's gonna be wide
open right and that is not an
exaggeration and there is you know I've
told y'all this Bill Cowher we laughed
before the draft talking about the
quarterbacks I said to him damn I think
the coordinator might be more important
the quarterback can he thought because
you see I last I think you're right and
so you know these court and there is
such a discrepancy in the top group to
the next group in the NFL and that's why
I just hate coaching is really important
and that's why so many teams don't have
a chance to win win big time yeah love
you Phil oh yeah yeah I'm glad we let
you talk a little today man I miss
hearing your voice do you yeah I do I am
that's actually I was gonna bring one
weekend a summer here so man Chris have
been talking I come up July 4th you saw
Phil I want to drink some some brews
with you I want to hang out I don't know
mister you know maybe not your life
really I swear to you I don't like to
curse but I am gonna look like a horse's
ass on July 4 it why because I have to
get some things done well I mean it's
all right we're not bruna he's not
taking pictures you to be in GQ magazine
that's like I honestly felt like if you
look like this was your head was wrapped
I wouldn't give a [ __ ] I'm not there for
your loss putting you on GQ magazine or
trying to date you or anything don't
worry I got a little prize son I know
okay he's gonna he's coming up at some
point here in the next few get it done
if it has to be July 4 no it does not
gonna be ready that was just fine I just
I need to scout for the draft party next
year I need to see if it's gonna be able
to hold all those people hey brother
when you see the setup you're gonna go
oh my god yes oh don't worry all right
we'll take everybody out Instagram I
don't
you know I can't do much of anything but
one thing my yard and my lake and all
that you know Hey look you mess with us
you come up here we'll throw your butt
in the lake and it's loaded with
snapping turtles so there's I'm gonna be
what I can go oh yeah my house is cool
you're gonna love my lake the best moat
it's got a great house Seas is what my
junior year in college they got this
piece of property this older woman that
lived in our town did not want to sell
it to contractors and my dad said I
promise you that's why the back is so
big it's a big yes 25 acres you've got
the lake but cheap because I promise you
I'm gonna knock down your house and I'm
gonna build myself a house and I won't
put anything else on this is not gonna
become like a coal de sac with 30 houses
on it and she said okay then I'll sell
it to you no trust me here my name is
not a great house the blood Dave this is
this is I made me think of we used to
have I've told you about the Hooper
right that we had there like a few years
ago does anybody know what a Hooper is
no idea Hooper is a swan but they're
really from lund England they have
yellow beaks instead of the pink be very
regal they're very regal but they're
ultra aggressive and my family got into
like oh we have this lake let's save
swans who were like broken wings or
whatever and they started doing that and
then they got they had a swan few Swan
sir then they got this Hooper and this
Hooper was just that I mean og NWA Ice
Cube gangster okay I mean he really was
where did they get it from from England
oh they got it from like it's like
wildlife centres around the area
whatever something like that you know I
mean to where they needed to help and my
mom was like I knew the woman she call
will take him on our lake sure and so
this thing ran all the other swans off
the lake and they just left because they
really he was non-stop all he did was
patrol the lake and trying to bite
everybody but then the lake wasn't
enough he decided the Simms backyard is
my territory too and my the big [ __ ]
we're talking big phil simms I just try
to picture this for a second I'm
imagining him trying to punch the Hooper
well I punched it because the things
stood up to Charlotte and bit Charlotte
once to where I had to kick it like and
didn't hurt it because but I just
thought family that loves animals they
sure do punch in yeah
I've what other ones that are here right
the dog the dad stuff but so so either
way either way but this thing's becoming
a nuisance to the fact where I can't let
my kids go in the backyard so what a big
field is so big fill one day this thing
is always on patrol now it's extra
aggressive this thing when big phil was
in his own swimming pool this was his
last draw got out of the lake walked
over to the swimming pool grabbed it by
the neck and attacked my dad why he was
in the pool my dad was having to swim
underwater because this thing was on top
of him with his neck under whatever just
trying to bite them they shoot their
wings out like this whoa and they can
hunt you right that's what they did to
Charlotte that's why I had to get
involved in one day because he started
hitting Charlotte and bruised her and I
was like damn so what did your dad do
finally got out I guess somehow someway
but it's just hilarious to think of big
Phil 6 3 250 running from a submarine
under the water right alright so your
boy Keyshawn Johnson has a comment about
Jameis Winston you wanna hear it yeah
when I saw the Jameis report I thought
man you just can't stay out of trouble
and there's something and I'm not a
doctor nor do I plan on being but
there's something wrong with you
if this is in fact true the fact you
keep coming up with some type of sexual
behavior problems towards women there's
something wrong mentally I don't care
what anyone says there's something wrong
what do you think do you think do you
echo key Sean's opinion there well non
non MD he would not have MD on his
Jersey he would not and neither would I
yeah I think there's some troubling
things here that to me would be there's
something more to this yeah whether it's
the way he looks at women or portrays
them in his own mind there's something
there that is troubling to me there's
certainly yeah I mean there's like I
said there's no way to defend Jameis
Winston anymore NFL reaction is oh man
we'll see if Ryan Fitzpatrick can handle
those first three games
yeah human reaction is are they gonna
welcome him back in week four I haven't
liked how is that fan base now that you
have all this traction you know he's
gonna get booed when he runs on the
field you think so I do yeah I think I
think this is enough I don't think this
is over
yet oh no you know what I mean like I
think this is I'm still not holding this
out to wear this like maybe Tampa Bay
when all said and done here just like
you know what don't even come back just
we'll go somewhere else next you know we
saw something happened with Greg Hardy
now Greg Hardy is fighting in like a UFC
yes but that was
it was very documented very present he
stilled like denies it and says you know
according to the courts I'm innocent
but Jameis is a quarterback and we see
how the NFL treats quarterbacks
differently there's a lot of
hypotheticals here you know I don't know
how you can get behind somebody like I
think is extremely hard I'd have a hard
time I'd have a hard time if I was in
the NFL locker room or anything being in
there with Jameis Winston I was gonna
say if he's looking I'm looking at the
same way yeah he'd be a guy that I would
probably steer clear of I really would
just like hey hey Jameis that's it
that's all he's getting from me like I
can't I can't what if he came over and
addressed it and he had something that
where I was a glue I haven't heard that
part of the story or that makes sense
you know me I'm an open minded guy I'm
not gonna just sit here and just go all
what no but I heard it this way you're
an [ __ ]
yeah certainly but again this is like be
gone beyond like where there's smoke
there's fire it's like where there's
fire there's fire like this is what it
is that's where we're at right now with
this certain subject and yeah I'm
disappointed and actually out of all the
times again I got reiterate out of all
the times we've seen the NFL be too
harsh with suspensions I think this is
one case where I'd go six games might
have been appropriate and he's getting
three and I did
yeah I'm really bothered by it because I
I was a Jameis Winston fan and I am no
longer random fan question John cool ro
Sims would you rather have a tall and
lanky corner like Xavier Rhodes or a
short and muscular corner like Darrelle
Revis yeah that's a that's a really good
one those are great questions and that's
a it's a it's a tough thing to answer
completely I think if you asked me at
the end of the day I would rather go
with the Darrelle Revis type yeah I
would
I always thought length was length is
great yes but Xavier Rhodes has trouble
with certain size receivers or Richard
Sherman we've seen at trouble because
their change of directions
are usually not that good because of the
length and the the glossiness per se as
compared to an antonio brown or an Odell
Beckham jr. who was having to cover so
Xavier Rhodes awesome but I think like
guys like Darrelle Revis where he's
special to is his strength is up there
with Xavier Rhodes that's how special he
was at the line of scrimmage and then
the change direction and speed in his
prime where every bit as good or better
than Xavier Road so yeah that's a great
question
like the Jalen Ramsey's of the world
Jalen Ramses is like in Xavier roads but
he's better at the change of direction
stuff where tour we'll see how that
plays out maybe he could be a guy that
can challenge a Darrelle Revis to where
I go okay maybe he's the type of mole
sure but no Darrelle Revis again second
greatest corner I've seen in my lifetime
it was interesting because I saw Jalen
Ramsey on NFL Network talking about how
he defends different wide receivers he
said Hopkins
he knows that Hopkins wants to bully
people so he wants to punch him too I
create two to three seconds and then you
ain't gonna outrun me right Antonio
Brown he says that he has to be
completely square right Antonio could go
either way the line is gonna try and be
over Antonio where he'd rather be under
DeAndre Hopkins but then when they
brought up Keenan Allen yeah he was like
man that guy's crazy yeah he was at
Keenan Allen's trying to cross you up
it's like playing a basketball player
and he kind of spoke and I it made me
think you know we always talk lately
it's been about the big four big five
right Antonio
Julio Odell Beckham DeAndre Hopkins and
I think we throw in AJ Green too but I
don't know if we've ever really given
Keenan Allen the love that I feel like
NFL players actually give well he's like
a you know he's like nuanced that's what
I would say Keenan Allen scheme Allen's
not scaring anybody with his athletic
prowess right I mean it's the same guy
we saw in the quarter the wide receiver
competitions at the Pro Bowl who
couldn't even finish the wide receiver
drill and couldn't even jump over the
bag and remember all that do you know
that we talked about it stop killing
brain cells but key
is like a mind he screws with your mind
with his route running that's what he
does see that on film you can see that
because he can make the out route look
like the out route and then come out the
very next one and go hey this looks just
like the out route BAM I've gone inside
and I think that's where he plays that's
why that's what he means by cross
exactly how do you do that well it just
he's very he's great at going how do I
make this route look the same how can I
make this route look like that route in
my mind he's gonna play with those in
practice you also have to keep almost a
running count of what you're doing to
the DB during the game - ooh last time I
broke outside I went outside yeah you
know I've gone outside on this outside
route like three times in a row now I'm
gonna make it look like that again
because I think he's gonna be ready for
this Simon I'm gonna go inside if that's
where like Jerry Rice was next-level
stuff because not only was the physical
ability stuff but he toyed with your
mind in the route running department to
where guys are they don't know any clues
or context of what to look for with hips
or feet ready go oh I have a feel when
his hips get like this he's going in or
out I wrote down Torry Holt yes that a
similar very similar guy he's more
athletically gifted but yes glory hole 1
yes 20 hole was but again yes it's that
type of guy where they are always
thinking about the routes they've run
here's the play what have I done to this
guy already what did I watch all week on
film and what am I gonna continue to do
to mess with him because I can't just
release outside and go I can beat him
because I'm so strong and fast every
play another wide receiver that we never
talk Emmanuel Sanders could be in that
conversation too except again I would
say he has more athletic ability than a
Keenan Allen - but the same kind of guy
where our golden tape Golden Tate would
be similar as well yes Golden Tate is
extremely quick I do think he has a leak
quickness that gives him a little
separation there as far and he's
toughest now but he is smart as hell the
other guy that I feel like his career is
coming to an end
Larry Fitzgerald no that would be
another guy why do we not in all these
conversations like Larry in his prime
was in my mind a top-10 where I receiver
of all time yeah in terms of his
physical ability his smarts his
discipline his ability to get yack
yeah he was a leaper like people forget
when larry fitzgerald first came into
the league it was if you throw it up
he's the only guy coming down with one
of the greatest 50/50 ball guys ever
then why are we never talking about him
as one of the greatest ever never comes
up no you're right
he's humble play with some [ __ ] yes he
did three years a Kurt Warner and then
who else you're right so that's part of
the problem it is Arizona he reminds me
a lot of Hopkins in terms of that is
much I say he's more physically gifted
than Hopkins he's humble he doesn't try
to put himself on a pedestal so he's
that guy that gets lost in the show most
100 perception guy yeah I know he is and
he misses he misses I think the this
sexiness big-time play and I and I would
say well Carragher career I know but he
had all the sexiness I know but think
about the play against Green Bay in the
playoffs that overtime catch when he ran
across the whole field and had six right
has great moments yes some good moments
Super Bowl Pittsburgh an incredible
planning of the Red Sea slate from our
Tennessee Titans how we beat Pittsburgh
in the regular season that was our play
he was at Pittsburgh he was like Calvin
Johnson he was very much Calvin Johnson
this I just think that's the reason why
he doesn't get the respect we think of
him because we don't see those highlight
plays throughout his career again left
go you're totally right he's top ten
number three all-time in yards and he's
gonna pass Randy this year right he's
300 about 400 yards behind Terrell Owens
in terms of receiving yards gonna pass
him this year yeah and then in terms of
receptions he is number three and Jason
Witt was number four and he's he's less
than a hundred behind Tony Gonzalez for
receptions so he could finish at like
two and and to write for receptions and
yards and I never hear him being talked
about I think it's because of that
though cuz he's just not quite the Freak
athlete some of the other guy like moss
or teo or obj or julio are he's a freak
athlete don't get me wrong but I'm not
saying to their level to where like I
think really the big thing is gonna be
what he did with the ball in his hands I
know what you're saying he's had moments
of that but I don't think he's also the
guy when teams prepared for her Larry
Fitzgerald
he
just like all the big-time receivers
they had to do something and have a plan
for him so don't get me wrong there but
what they were planned for I'm worried
about with him they weren't worried
about him catching five-yard slants and
running 480 yard touchdowns that wasn't
his game and I think that's probably why
he doesn't quite get that commercial
appeal as the other guys I think the big
thing is this frickin quarter way and
that's - in Arizona there's no doubt no
doubt it's it's all over the place see
and that's why for me Larry Fitzgerald's
a great case is why I can't get upset at
Odell for the people that go out and
make a name for themselves
in the end the squeaky wheel gets the
grease right and and for someone like
Larry Fitzgerald who we want to say his
numbers will stand the test of time and
they will speak for it apparently not
you know that's why you need to
sometimes boast a little bit you need to
toot your own horn I don't think it'll
matter he's gonna be a first vial
hall-of-famer yes because of his stats
and because of how well he's respected
he will be like the anti TL Winnebago
you're written we don't have to vote
you're got it you see Daniel hunter got
a contract no I did not so my guy that I
picked to be Defensive Player of the
Year last year didn't get there he got
up he got a paycheck yeah five years
seventy million forty and guaranteed
with a fifteen million dollar signing
bonus they got a three defensive three
year forty million dollar contract it's
not bad not bad that's right for a guy
that that I don't think is hit a ceiling
yet definitely I'm hope I call them the
ballerina coming out of college remember
and I'm hope of course I remember again
and I'm hoping Sheldon Richardson oh I
think Sheldon Richardson
I hope opens up more for Daniel Daniel
hunter I think that's their plan is that
they're hoping that maker for Defensive
Player of the Year I mean they're that
they need somebody the Sheldon
Richardson where he's gonna help out the
Minnesota Vikings is the fact that you
do have to think about him and Linville
Joseph on the inside now and there's
gonna be certain teams are gonna go damn
we might have to you know we got a bad
guard over here we might have to double
one of these guys right right so that
that is where that comes into play again
my big question will be like we've
always talked about with them
it's they've signed one player on
offense and one guy on defense really
and depth is the issue with that
football especially on defense I don't
know if you guys saw this
- its man it's a little crazy what's
going on with it can't be generous
Jenkins because he's been down in
Florida for a while his brother is now a
suspect but I saw them but I'm just
curious - football perspective let's say
he he's not a part of this at all is
this time of the year where it's like
three weeks off is this a good time for
it to happen cuz you can like deal with
it cuz it's at your house and all that
or is it like this was my one time to be
off and now there's this crazy thing
that happened at my house yeah I get you
it's better to be dealing with it now I
mean even though it's he's he's saying
like what you're saying where he's going
like damn I got a deal with this but it
would be more of an annoyance if it
happened in August when he was at
training camp something like that the
Giants were pissed off it happened
during that time as well so yeah I mean
do we know for sure he was in Florida at
this time and we don't know anything are
so shallow in terms of details but I do
not think you can skim over the fact a
body was found at a premier NFL players
home no that in itself makes it
newsworthy yeah where we're going to
blame I'm not ready I don't even know
any of the evidence they just said that
they have a possible suspect Fair Lawn
New Jersey let's I mean what kind of
neighborhood is that it's a nice like
working man's middle middle upper class
type of town I mean good good rec sports
they were one of my rivals by yeah
Little League sports going up it's got a
little everything few cultures here and
there of course you've stayed there he
can have a nice house and he's not far
from giant stadium it means just a lot
of a super whoa whoa holy crap holy crap
is right it's like this is an
interesting story and it's gonna be
something that we watch develop but I
have no idea what the hell happened it's
there are two bodies found yesterday one
was there and then one there was like a
stadium where they found like a
contractor like a walk-in freezer oh
yeah brave okay it was at Turner Field I
guess man bodies just popping up it's I
just think again it I don't even know
how to say it just some of the guys in
the NFL and they're where they come from
and their upbringing that was the other
thing I thought and all of that stuff
it's just how many people are living at
that house just I mean it just it's it's
I don't think always Lyc
comprehensible in everybody's brains to
realize how some of these guys have
grown up what they're responsible for
how many people they have hanging around
them all of those things we never
support a family member try like my dad
was just talking about like he tried to
give a nice answer they're like dad
bought a lot of crap for his Kentucky
family okay I mean that's just the way
it goes right yes that's how it is
so yeah there's just so many things that
come to play and I know I've said it a
million times whether I played or work
for the New England Patriots after I
played the stories I was consistently
told throughout my career or after my
career about how some guys were raised
or things they had to go through at an
early life is truly phenomenal and it's
amazingly sometimes even made it to
where they were where I'm like gosh how
did he overcome all that and I am
interested to see how this plays out
it's gonna be New York one of the
highest-paid players in the football
team so yeah I mean it's a big year yes
generous needs to show up because we
don't know about Eli Apple I want to say
one thing before we start wrapping up it
came out recently Lamar Jackson was
asked you know which teams actually
asked you to want to play wide receivers
and he said it was actually the Chargers
which goes back to we always knew the
Chargers we're looking at a quarterback
and they're probably just asking that
question
the Ravens didn't ask the question but
then put him at wide receiver anyway so
it's okay but he said in his answer
that's the reason he didn't run the 40
is he didn't want people to connect the
dots that he was a wide receiver and I
want to say this damn it it is upsetting
to me that we will never officially know
Lamar Jackson's 40 time it's upsetting
it is because for me like I went back
and I went oh Larry if it's show around
a four for eight we were looking earlier
like David Johnson oh he ran a four for
whatever and Dominique Rodgers Cromartie
ran a four to eight four to nine the
fact that I'm never gonna know what
Lamar Jackson ran in the 40 feels
criminal yeah it feels like there was an
amazing movie that a few people got to
watch and I'll never know how it ends
yeah and it's like I would love for
Lamar Jack now that Lamar's on a team
Ravens can we just run
come to set up a little timer little
laser it's only gonna make your fanbase
go whoa big offseason
no one's now wondering about the switch
to wide receiver you've impressed
everybody at camp
can we please let them run the 40 give
us Lamar's 40 I show what you mean what
about his emails
I need Lamar's 40 it's just it's out
there it's still attainable I still
think that NFL players should run the 40
before every season just to compare how
they were since the combo yes I check up
with the doctor yes I don't think that
Eli is running the same 40 that he
didn't back that maybe Tom Brady would
like to improve upon his he probably
could improve on that's what I'm saying
I just I would like updates I'd like to
weigh these guys before every season I'd
like to check their height or the weight
you're getting is religion I can promise
you that before I thought they'd still
use the combine waiting for a guy three
years they will like at the start of
training camp but once you get to like
like you know those things that we see
an NFL GSIS yeah that will have some
legitimate weights because that it's
gonna become those little yeah the depth
charge yeah but I just I need to me
that's one of the things that will go
down in NFL lore that we never got to
see is Lamar Jackson so fast you think
even run it I think he's like don't say
it yet you think of a number you think
of a number you think of a number people
out there think of a number what would
Lamar Jackson get in the 40 give me a
sec I got mine it's based on absolutely
nothing but I got it I'm gonna say four
to nine okay what was yours who's gonna
go for four four Wow I went for three
one yeah I mean it's always right so
this is where I go to nine drive me
crazy yeah I am I'm gonna put him what
do you guys think what would he have run
this is where okay so like I'm with you
I want to see him run he should have
done it I wish he would have done it
just to get some positive propaganda out
there pre-draft like we always said
still won first right yeah he's still
won first round really good the other
thing I would say is just really who
gives a damn I do I know you do
apparently but I'm just telling you
you're telling me that I shouldn't give
a damn about one of the best athletes to
ever come into our store
have one unit of measurement that even
though it does not matter it's still
incredible to watch John Brown run a
four to four it's still incredible to
watch Chris Jackson on a four to nine
four two four and when he gets on the
field he's slower than four four four
Odell Beckham I don't care when or
Jackson is someone that has blessed us
on the field successfully and
athletically yeah and I just want to see
it happen I get it but I don't you know
I'm telling you it from the players
podcast point of view knew Lamar Jackson
screw left go you don't have to run the
40 it's too late he's in the NFL and
when nobody can catch him we're just
gonna go damn he's for fast damn who
gives a damn it doesn't matter like
Michael Vick ran a 4-3-3
according to some random brain but
whatever it is it doesn't matter not to
go so if Mike Vick was four three three
bar Stein I don't know it doesn't matter
because I've seen Michael Vick in person
and I saw other guys in the field that
clocked faster than Michael Vick and
when I may ran on the football field I'm
just telling you they weren't as fast as
Michael Vick so I don't the forty is
just a little bit of a clue context it's
not an end-all by I'm going to contact
some of my Louisville pay people a zoo
and I'm gonna see if you have around the
40 oh I guarantee it'll Louisville he
definitely did college I need to know
those times yeah because I feel I feel
job I think you're gonna see or four to
everybody out there knows we don't
numbers let us know correct shad alright
so next week we are still going to do
two podcast one on Monday one on
Wednesday Wednesday is July 4th a little
early thing for you right now we are
going to be doing another Sims and left
go fan question segment mailbag next
Wednesday you guys killed it so much so
that uh mister SVP came up to us said
well the fans actually had really good
questions you overflowed Fender ik
vendrick we'll put out another request
ask any questions you have questions be
weirder next time for questions last
let's get Jen's
yeah have questions maybe we'll get big
Phil on for the mag mailbag would you
want that and of course he's down so
yeah so if you want to throw questions
out to the big [ __ ] let's do that but
like I know like rod simulator is like I
I didn't realize the me asking your
middle name
would lead to poor names yes that's good
yes oh yeah this Stonewall is clamoring
for more I would also like questions I
would also like self scouting if you
think that we need to fix stuff do stuff
we're down for that we'll get dangerous
we're in the whoa big offseason and
we're building right now so it's a lot
of fun so thank you to Ice Cube
you were the man we will indeed stay up
thank you for signing that that was
completely impromptu thank you to big
phil simms bill [ __ ] big [ __ ] always
bringing it in yeah
and if I do get to go to his house soon
I'm gonna use the Sims and left go
Instagram account and do like a little
showcase big film Kyrie Irving said
Harden is people's MVP LeBron is the
NBA's entropy interesting sorry football
podcast descended on the Kyrie Irving
yes just saw it all right cool
for Sims he's out homies for Fenric good
evening everybody and for the Elliott ko
he drove them crazy that I did that for
the lef koe man thank you guys thank you
I love you guys have a great weekend
we'll be back on monday hit us up
anywhere dm's iTunes get your questions
and for Wednesday's July 4th show I'll
holler at you peace